have to play down a queen for some
material but vidit he makes the draw he
wants the white pieces and he trades
Queen so this variation is all the rage
but Donna is it a good bullet opening
I think it's okay I mean if you know all
of the typical ideas for white if you
know exactly where the pieces belong I
think that white can play this in bullet
I'm a little bit worried though because
Magnus knows absolutely everything and
this G5 G4 idea I think is recommended
by Erwin Lami uh in his uh chessable
course on the chorus Magnus clearly
showing that he's done his homework here
Magnus looking at chess games who would
have thought it if you ever watched the
documentary on Magnus he devours all
material on the game of chess it sort of
shows based on his skill set but look at
this just bring your knight to F4
controlling these dark squares what does
white have in this position as black
will of course play H5
nothing Knight G2 whoa
that's such a good move you want your
stage six
wow
incredible but this is this is just this
is positional Mastery in a bullet gaming
this is unprecedented the way and the
way that Magnus is improved you know if
you look at his bullet performances over
the last couple of years how much faster
he's got how much crisper at bullet
tactics it's insane
he's threatening Checkmate right if the
bishop moves and a rook gets the d8 god
the white King has no moves that's
vulgar
get that out of the commentary we've got
kids watching wait you can play it
anyway
well Bishop V6 the Knight can take
that's the good news because it covers
the d8 square but then how are you gonna
cover it doesn't matter and if Knight
takes B7 you just go Rook V8 but Magnus
going very very positional here can't
really blame him he wants to play with
an abundance of caution he's still much
better because of his Monopoly over the
dark squares all over the board
this looks great Bishop here open space
that Knight on C3 completely dominated
by the opponent on C6 I think that it's
you know nice to play Bishop E6 when
you're a commentator but it would have
shattered Black's Pawn structure whereas
this position there is no harm and
everything is looking good for magnets
his piece is operating in concert like a
practice Philharmonic
uh Symphony it's crazy every piece
fulfilling its own roll Rook G2
apparently wins the game with a
beautiful sequence of Bishop checks he's
gonna find it you know it you know it no
he doesn't
still winning not not that easy to spot
in a bullet game but this looks great
for black you're trying to weaken to
loosen the pawn chain and go after the
base pawn and what we take for granted
so often are magnus's play is I really
like to draw attention to how he plays
on both sides of the board it's it it
produces an aesthetic effect even to
someone who barely knows the rules of
the game look at how one move is on the
queen side then the other on the king's
side then they gather in the center he
uses the board as his canvas to produce
beautiful paintings whether it's bullet
or Blitz or classical and look at this
Checkmate on G4
that is sick